-Our next guess is a great actor
who stars in and produced
the new movie "Archenemy,"
which is theaters, on demand,
and on digital next Friday.
Here is Joe Manganiello!
Yo! Wow!
-Hey, Jim.
-Lookin' good, bud.
Whoa, whoa, whoa! Is that...
Is that real? No more...
-This is real.
This is freshly shaved
as of this morning.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-No more Mohawk.
But it's amazing how much --
Like, a Mohawk
is that much hair.
But you take it off,
and you're freezing.
-Joe, what am I see
in the corner of the screen?
Is there a special guest?
-[ Chuckles ] Yeah.
This is my sidekick.
-Yes!
-This is -- This is --
-Oh, no!
This is -- This is Bubbles.
-Bubbles. Hi, Bubbles.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
I appreciate it. Oh, my gosh.
-[ Chuckles ]
-How cute is that. Oh, my God.
-This is Bubbles'
first appearance
on "The Tonight Show."
-And will not be her last.
So, Bubbles, you're allowed back
whenever.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Joe, there's a ton of stuff
I want to talk to you about,
But, first, congrats.
I know you just celebrated
your five-year
wedding anniversary
with your lovely wife,
Sofía Vergara.
Congrats on that.
We've talked before about how
you and Sofía started dating.
But you -- were you always
smooth when it came to dating?
Because I want to know
about this guy.
This...
-That guy -- not so smooth
with the dating, Jimmy.
Yeah, not so smooth.
-Look at the arms, bud.
Oh, my gosh.
-Mm-hmm.
-Dude, when did it change?
[ Both laugh ]
-It changed around age 16.
Then, I got contact lenses,
and the working out
was starting to happen.
All the protein shakes
were starting to take effect.
And I also -- I got a phone call
from a friend of mine,
who said, you know, "How'd you
like to make 25 bucks an hour?"
At age 16, you say, "Sure.
What do I have to do?"
They said, "Just come down
to our office.
Whatever anybody says to you,
what they ask,
just say you're 21."
And I didn't have a license
at this time,
so I had to have my mother come
drop me off at their office.
And there was a bunch of adults,
and they said --
you know, I walked in, they
said, "You're the guy?"
I said, "Yeah."
They said, "How old are you?"
I said, "21."
They go, "Great. Put this on."
And they handed me
this pirate suit,
with the cape and the eye patch
and the wig and the ruffles,
the hat, I had a sword.
I had a pistola.
The little fake booties
that go over your shoes
to make them look
like they're real boots.
-Yeah. What were you?
-And I was gonna go
be Captain Morgan at a bunch
of bars in Pittsburgh.
-Wow!
-And they gave me a backpack
that was a tank
with a tap on it, full of rum.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-So I went --
-Do you still have that?
-Go get everyone drunk.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-So, that led to, like,
you know, probably
the next decade,
I worked in bars.
You know, that's how I worked
until, like, acting took off
where I could pay my bills
that way as an artist.
I was working in clubs,
and so, like,
that Captain Morgan job,
then, when I was 21 --
I worked as Captain Morgan
in Pittsburgh from 16 to 21.
And then, when I was 21,
I got a job working
for Finlandia vodka,
where I would go out U2's
old tour bus full of vodka.
We would drive to every
major city in America.
I was in a tuxedo this time.
It was a little classier.
-Yeah, you upped your game.
-Get everybody drunk.
So it was, like, just nonstop
wall-to-wall bar jump.
But what the point is,
circling back, is
that that was the best education
in men and women and dating.
When you are in a club,
night after night,
watching the animals hunt
in the wild...
-Wow.
-...you learn a lot.
So that scrawny kid really got
his formal education
in women and men and dating
and all that.
-And look at you now.
I mean, come on.
I mean, we know you
as this giant movie star.
And I know that, growing up,
wasn't your original dream
to also be
a writer and director?
-Well, yeah, as a kid,
that's actually
how I got into acting.
I made all my own movies,
where you do, like,
Mafia martial arts movies...
with, like, gunshots
and, you know, squib.
We made homemade squibs
when we were kids.
-You made a homemade squib,
like a blood-explosion squib?
-Yeah, so, we would take
a firecracker,
and then you'd take a condom
and you'd fill the condom
with Karo syrup
and red food coloring.
You tie it up.
And you get a cookie tin.
And you could, like --
If you got really brave,
you'd put the cookie tin,
like, over your heart.
So we'd cut the shirt
a little bit,
so the wick would come out.
And then you had to turn
the camera on someone's hand.
They had to come in
and light the lighter, the wick,
and then get your hand out
so that we could get the shot.
"Oh!" You know, and
you'd fall over
and, you know, have
this flap of skin,
and blood would gush out
everywhere.
-Joe, that was probably
a real flap of real skin.
You lit a firecracker
on someone's chest.
-It was --
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-Yeah, it was painful, yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
That is unbelievable.
Uh, uh, I, uh --
I want to talk
about your new movie.
It's called "Archenemy."
And I love the premise.
I've never seen
a movie like this.
I would say it's
a superhero movie.
But it's more than
It's -- It's a trickier plot.
Basically -- DO you want me
to set it up?
You basically land
on a planet.
And you're like,
"On Earth, I'm a superhero."
-Well, maybe. You don't know.
-Right.
-That's the thing, is, like,
everything that you just said
is absolutely true, you know,
but, you know,
is it a superhero movie,
or is it not?
Because, really,
the bulk of it is,
I play a maybe borderline
schizophrenic character
who's also addicted to
methamphetamine and alcohol
and lives in a tent
under a bridge
and babbles on and on and on
to anybody
who will listen to him
about being
some sort of champion
or Superman, superhero
from another dimension.
So, really, is an exploration
about whether or not
he's crazy,
or is it actually true.
-Again, I don't like to spoil
anything, but it's great.
And I want to
show everyone a clip.
Here's Joe Manganiello
in "Archenemy."
Take a look.
-You cannot run.
Hey, I don't care what you do.
You make bad choices,
you live with them.
It's fine, but the kid deserves
his own chance.
If you run, they will find you,
and they will kill him.
-So, what are we supposed to do?
-You stay and you fight the war.
-Hamster, don't engage
with the troll.
-Fight the war?
-[ Scoffs ]
-How are we supposed to do that?
-Don't undersell yourself.
I'm here with you.
I fell through a black hole
to get here.
And I never knew why until now.
It was so I could help you.
Both of you.
♪♪
-Aww. What did you think, buddy?
Oh, he loved it.
[ Chuckling ] He loved it.
Joe Manganiello, everybody.
"Archenemy" is in theaters,
on demand, and on digital,
starting December 11th.
Thank you so much
for coming on, bud.
It's always great to see you.
-Hey, man, thank you so much.
I love being here.
It's so great.
I have so much fun with you.
-Stay safe.